climate change Fanatics now declaring
war on the most green thing in your home
house plants yep the ferns you never
water is the thing that's going to kill
mother earth The Washington Post trying
to shame people with this headline you
ready quote indoor house plants come
with a cost to the planet here's how to
minimize it Greening indoor spaces can
also come in an environmental cost the
trucks that transport plants spew carbon
emissions plastic pots and synthetic
fertilizers are made from petroleum and
the Harvest in of soil components like
Pete can tear up slowly forming habitats
instead they suggest you look for local
plant swaps or garden clubs in your area
meanwhile Joe Biden's green Jihad is a
total disaster a giant offshore wind
project that the White House gloated
about just got killed like one of the
birds that fly into them two big energy
developers announced they are cancelling
the contract for a massive wind project
slated for construction just off the
coast of New York because of
inflation Greg Gutfeld uh do you have
any plants in your house yeah I actually
have a lot of plants I don't water them
that's for the wife as you know my God
she Waters a Barefoot that's the only
way I have it you I think you're
witnessing kind of the last final gasp
of the climate change movement you're
seeing a lot of hysterical activity
people are beginning to realize the
public that if it wasn't for the
hysterics we might have made progress in
some real areas for example like nuclear
power but instead you had activists out
for attention personal gain and
Consultants out for profit that turned
this into a circus reality is now
punching right through the hysteria the
risk from climate related disasters has
dropped 99% since 1920 and why is that
it's not because of activism it's
because of innovation and human progress
which has made us more resilient as you
know they bring up they talk about
fertilizer well if you want to go there
four billion people rely on fossil
fertilizer izer if you're going to take
that away they starve to death they're
not lucky enough to get their lattes and
their pumpkin bread at Starbucks after
they block traffic so actually climate
hysteria brought to its their desires
would be genocidal you'd have four
billion people dead so I think that like
when you you think of the opportunity
costs of all this what problems could
you have solved if you hadn't spent
billions and trillions on a lie these
climate models are all false there's no
way you can predict people can't predict
10 years in time we would have we would
have been able to address world hunger
disease sanitation homelessness instead
of going to climate conferences and and
paying Consultants even the NASA
satellites are now admitting that like
the world is burning less no it's not on
fire it's not on fire so uh I think
what's happening is now when you're
going after the house plants it's over
yeah I mean they said it was going to
snow this weekend let's see if it snows
they can't predict what's going to
happen on Sunday but they're going to
tell us what the temperature is in 100
years sander um I wrote down a couple
things a I just want to say it's very
therapeutic to be here with you guys
tonight I always laugh it's always fun
um house plants house plants Jess gu can
help you with them especially orchids I
think I gave you an orchid best L is
gorgeous it is gorgeous the best thing
you can do with orchids is neglect just
neglect them I'm not
children not with children um listen I
have I have a challenge to this White
House
we are now seeing oil production at a
record high in this country right now
what's happening there I went and pulled
up Biden's campaign messages of the last
election are you saying he doesn't mean
what he says he says he said he wanted
remember when he whispered to the little
kid I we're going to end fossil fuels
we're going to transition from the oil
industry he said in a major campaign
speech the White House will not respond
now to the Press who was asking about
the increasing levels of crude oil
production as the president continues to
push this green agenda again Fox digital
reached out this week the White House
failed to respond to inquiries and
address um to address the figures um in
light of the climate change agenda why
are we producing record amounts under
this Administration maybe Joe doesn't
know it see that's what we're talking
about he doesn't necessarily know what
his administration oil industry doing it
well I mean but that is a good question
I mean if if oil production is up and
windmill projects are getting canceled
left and right what's actually going on
well what's going on is maybe uh middle
management is recognizing the benefits
to oil production and there's a lot of
lobbyists who are just saying this is
what we want and they getting it done
and a lot of them will respond that
we're seeing these This Record
production as a result of what happened
years prior like because a lot of these
leases are years in the making and but
he was cancelling the leases I mean that
that was the problem did Biden correct
yes and that will play out all right
play out in the future but you know what
made me crazy about this when he said
that you know the house plants were
creating a problem it's like to them
what is their solution number one you're
supposed to buy plants locally okay we
buy plants locally where do you think
they got started with the plant you
don't think they use Pete you don't
think that they use any kind of you know
fertilizer for those plants that you
bought that are so gorgeous of course
they did and then they want me to get
rid of my gas stove which I'll get rid
of Over My Dead Body and then what they
want is you know they want us to be my
guess though what do you how do you how
much do you think that affects the
environment I mean you got John KY and
MD judge flying around in private jets
and they're worried about my gas stove
Lea blowers too judge yeah those too the
leaf blowers so I should have a house
with no plants in it unless I want to
borrow it from my neighbor okay and then
I should not have a gas stove I
shouldn't be able to cook they have no
solution for any of this because it's
not a problem unless their solution is
they don't want us to eat meat because
of the cow's flatulence right sooner or
later they're going to say you know
humans emit carbon too get rid of them
get rid of the humans you know if you're
over 80 maybe we don't need that's what
they're doing in Canada huh that's what
they're doing in Canada they're pushing
youth in Asia because there's just too
many people much farting yeah no too
many people too many people whatever the
reason is they're going to start
controlling and eliminating us and it
gets more important as the show goes on
later block I'll talk about it I am
excited um for the later blocks about
that um I'm glad we're all admitting
that we have record oil production so
good cuz on Tuesday I had to fight you
guys on that one but if it wasn't what
would you do but I mean you're actually
agree I agree with you I think it's
great but that but so you're saying like
I'm I'm for this but since it's not
happening hooray this is true yeah Joe
Biden said he wants to get rid of oil
and gas I
know liar is he lying to the americ
activists are going after the ad I
understand they have well they have been
he canceled a pipeline and they've been
pissed at him from the
beginning what oh I know no no no no no
no on that one um I think it's important
if someone sees the error of their ways
and we live in a forgiving society and
he says actually drilling is the right
way to approach this and he did by the
way also give a lot more leases to drill
on Federal Land something that did upset
his base and we talk about that he's
losing young people because his climate
agenda is not nearly as green as it
quote should be why why don't you give
him the pat on the back that he deserves
apology accepted pat on the back drill
baby drill coming around you guys all
flowers over the weekend stop trying to
pretend like you were going to get rid
of it and then it's boosted hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else